non-minimalists
what should we do with old dvds and cds
especially those that contain films and
music that we like to keep in some form
so let's talk about dvds let's talk
about cds
uh so emma cds are like um
how do i explain this
we have some gen zeros here that yeah
uh
let's see no so they're so antiquated
it's like oh my like uh walking down
hollywood
um because i used to take that path to
the office not anymore so don't try and
stalk me patrons
but there's always the guys who have the
cds yeah hey man how you doing i'm just
just out here slinging cds which by the
way don't ever ever accept a cd from
someone on the sidewalk yeah it's never
free and not only can they try to get
money out of you they're going to try
and get as much time as they can out of
you anyway unless you're interested in
buying their music then right
of course but like they would come up to
me like hey i'm giving away free cds and
i would be like dude i don't have a way
to play that
like i don't even know how i would
listen to that right yeah anyway and so
that's the thing
ask yourself do you actually want to get
rid of your dvds and cds that might
sound weird coming from one of the
minimalists but if you're using your cds
yeah if you're using your dvds why get
rid of them why get rid of them you're
asking this question though likely
because it is burdening you i got rid of
my dvds and cds
because
like my ear can't pick up on the
difference between
vinyl and a cd and a digital
in the digital form of a song an mp3
well especially with what apple's doing
now with um their lossless technology
and their surround sound technologies
some of these are even going to
eventually be better they're already
better than cd some of them may even be
better that this is preference right
sure than analog right i know henry
rollins who lives near here he has like
a two hundred thousand dollar setup and
he only listens to records or cassettes
he'll only listen to analog versions of
the music because he prefers the sound
on these really expensive speakers and
so yes he has the ability
to
listen to these things and he uses them
now
why am i going to go to henry rollins
house saying why do you have all these
cassettes why do you because i used them
right and i would be doing him a
disservice if i said well you need to
declutter these you you need to get rid
of them it's going to free you up no
it's not he gets incredible joy from the
experience that he he receives from
these over and over and over however
those things may have brought you joy in
the past the dvds and the cds but now if
you have the digital version of those
and that's how you listen to your music
that's how you watch your your movies
man
i'm gonna get rid of them because
they're simply in the way now what can
you do with them you can still sell them
i mean i know that's wild but amoeba
music here in la they will take old used
music now they might pay you a quarter
or 50 cents
but if you have a thousand cds that's
going to add up it's better than sitting
there taking up space
on your shelf but also that space that
is taking up in your mind it's stressing
you out it's overwhelming you and if
that's the case maybe it's time to let
go
yeah
i don't think i own any cds or dvds i
own one cd it's in my cd player in my
car i haven't
i don't man i wasn't saying i think i
had like a minimalism dvd but i gave it
away
it's a hoarder on the street that's
right take this did you enjoy this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free